live from south by southwest 2013. in
austin texas
yo it's power 98.3 bootleg.com uh we are
south by southwest chilling in the media
room right now with my dude representing
las vegas we got my guy dizzy right
what's popping g what's popping man hey
much love to you man you've come a long
way
dizzy d flashy bro yeah i remember the
first time i saw you bro was i i think
it was a chic remember that chic shoes
talent competition yeah that [__] was
like what mall was that uh
you saw it at the big mall or you saw it
in vegas oh yeah the boulevard the
boulevard mall yeah i was one of the
judges oh where yeah that was when i
first moved to vegas it was oh
and sean rose i think we're like yeah
yeah that's crazy i didn't even know
that yeah man of the day homie that's
crazy that's where um
dame who's one of the owners of funk
volume came out like the the ending of
that like yeah
he came to that and that's like where
you first seen me do my thing that's
crazy
you know the rest is history man
um first of all congrats on everything
man um how is it
i guess being in the lane you're in now
man you were like one of the hottest
young dudes coming up in the game right
now it seems like
i know you've put a lot of work in um
you know you definitely put vegas on on
the map as far as hip hop right now
um what's it like man to kind of know
you're that first dude because i know
how important that city is to you and to
everybody from vegas yeah there's really
no identity for hip-hop but now it's
dizzy right you know what i'm saying
you're that first guy so you know what's
that feel like it's cool because i know
everybody in the city seeing the growth
you know what i'm saying like you were
just like you know like i just popped up
you know everybody know me from like
high school of course young cat just
running around doing all the shows and
uh just building like it's been a
building process and um pretty much with
youtube and just being on have heavy on
the internet
everybody's been pretty much just grown
with me i mean so i think that's the
best thing that people have [__] to go
back and look at
and um
everybody could just be proud of the
progress i mean i feel like you've been
making great music for for a long time i
know you did the one record i remember
seeing on youtube before before i i
really met you or really
rocked with any of your [__] was uh i
think it was like a letter to your
unborn son
yeah led it to my onboard child yeah
that [__] was deep man yeah man it's
crazy yeah it's crazy like the
progression but you've always had
because i know people kind of when i
first came to vegas did i get dizzy
dizzy's cool well you know he makes
jerking music or [__] like that but you
all you also had that side shoot this
whole time you know what i'm saying so
yeah definitely it's definitely a good
look um i know you're about to go on
tour with the cottonmouth kings yes i am
congratulations thank you man you
understand how crazy that's about to be
yeah i do
them fools is wild yeah we gonna be
smoking y'all about to smoke so much
weed on the way
snow going
snow is gonna be smoking with y'all
we're gonna get her high you're gonna
you you guys gonna get snow [__] up
yeah we're gonna get stoned
it's about to go down man so um let's
talk about this funk volume thing man
you guys are kind of carving your own
lane right now
i feel like um
you know strange music kind of laid the
blueprint and like funk volume is
running with that blueprint and doing
their own thing you know what i'm saying
as far as the independent game um
do you do you feel like a major is ever
in the question i know you have the
independent living song you know
is it but i always when i hear your
music i'm like yo teamwork make the
dream work as a song here on the radio
you know what i'm saying
do you ever see that in your future at
all the only thing that comes with like
the majors is just having to deal with
all the people right um so like right
now how i'm feeling like right now no
just simply because i like to keep my
circles small and everything is just
hands on right now it's not like all
over the place
and i just like it like that right now
so right now i feel like just being
independent is the best thing because i
like to be i like to have all the
creative control
and i don't have to deal with a lot of
[__] and my [__] is just real
organized and solid and i just want to
build that and this maintain record you
just put out with joey bass it's crazy
yeah i'm definitely [__] with it cool
it's some some super hip-hop [__] i [__]
with it um how did you guys link up man
cause i feel like on the west coast
you're probably like you know one of the
hottest i think
at least circles that i'm in people who
talk i think you're probably like the
hottest dude coming out of the west
coast right now on some awesome hip-hop
[__] you know what i'm saying appreciate
that bad ass on the east coast how'd you
guys link um some of his people like i
had met some of his peoples when i did a
show in new york a while back and then
um we had just like they just threw the
idea out and then i had to hit the
maintain track before i even met joey
and i was like i super want to get him
on it so we reached out to the people
and then we got in the studio at dj
premier studio oh word yeah and then he
just he hi right on it when he heard it
primo i didn't get to
i get to but i was chilling though that
would have been tight it was tight i was
chilling who else uh you know now that
you you got that buzz who's somebody
else who who's reached out or somebody
who you want to work with or who that's
in the works right now because i know a
lot of people got to be reaching out to
you right now
um
me and snow got some [__] we got some
dope [__]
um
i'm [__] with abs so i'm so stoked
yeah we're gonna come up with some [__]
a couple [__] like and then my inner
circle
yeah you know but um
anybody that's like got talent and you
know just
i'm feeling that [__] i'm a [__] with
him for sure let me ask you man being
that guy coming because you know i was
in vegas for three years and i feel like
vegas has got a lot of raw talent
that i feel like you might be the guy to
kick that door down for you know what
i'm saying
definitely who are like some artists out
of vegas that you feel like
you know are
are ready to go you know what i'm saying
some guys who co-sign out of the city
sean rose for sure rose i think rose has
his own lane i think he's dope um
capo young
young stoke that's how with nipsey that
blake griffin yeah [__] capo is really
he's serious he toured with you too yeah
well you guys did a little run together
right yeah like i wanted him to be on
more of the shows or whatever i told him
whatever he could get to right i could i
let him perform at but um yeah he came
out or whatever and did his thing but
yeah i feel like he could really go
somewhere if you just get focused and
just go hard i think that's a lot of
people's problem though man it's just
about you know there's real life there's
real life [__] going on with exactly
what i'm saying it's hard to focus on
jazz laser too jazz is dope yeah he's
definitely got his own lane and a lot of
energy on stage definitely definitely
man that's what's up man so uh you got
the album out you put the mixtape out
you put the ep out what's next for dizzy
i got a mixtape i'm about to drop again
um
we're just gonna do it all over i'm just
gonna keep making music while i'm
pumping it out and i mean just being
creative
and uh yeah so i'm gonna run with the
mixtape because i just want to give a
bunch of music away in the last like six
months what is i feel like you've you've
kind of changed places as far as being
like the the newest dude on funk volume
and now you know you're you're touring
with with codmouth kings you're selling
i mean you know you came to phoenix for
that futuristic show and them kids knew
all the words to your [__] bro it was
wild um
what is something that you've learned in
the last six months you know from from
from messing with with dame messing with
hops and something that you've taken
away from this entire experience
um really just um show love to the
people that show love to you
i mean like um the fans is everything
fans is really everything just people
forget sometimes yeah man you got to
show love if they [__] with you [__]
with them like i [__] with everybody
that [__] with me you know what i'm
saying so and just being humble about it
not being an [__] about it like oh i
got all these [__] [__] with me you
know what i'm saying just being humble
about it being cool about it and
honestly yo real [__] like
don't take yourself too serious right
right you know what i'm saying like i
saw you having fun on stage and [__]
sometimes everybody
yeah definitely everyone's being serious
yeah
you gotta have fun man still i agree
when's the new mixtape coming out
um i'm pushing for june
i'm pushing for joan um it might be
sooner [__] might be later i don't know
but around that time okay that's what's
up looking forward to that maintain will
be on that or maintain we'll be on that
yeah that's what's up my dude well i
appreciate your time disney right
representing vegas funk volume it's
bootleg.com